first viewing total lie of ex-military I
don't hate this movie like everyone else
it's it's not good okay so in the first
x-men movie came out I was like I think
is fair to say we're kind of
disappointed like but it's cool there's
x-men it's up there we finally got an
x-men movie and everyone's like oh you
just gotta relax it's ax men an x-men 2
came out and they say this is amazing
and I saw it I'm like I think of about
the same disappointed but I mean I guess
it's cool ZX it's like I'll just relax
just relax come on just go enjoy it so
finally with the third one I'm like okay
I'm gonna do them just gonna go in try
to have a good time turn my brain off
just enjoy that x-men are on the big
screen that's what I did I had a good
time I thought I was actually very
entertaining and everyone's like I have
some problems that's like why are we now
doing this and that was the most
entertaining out of them until I guess
the ending ending is where it's like
hardcore shit that was my take and
everyone hates me for it but I also
haven't seen it in years so uh ROVs
building up to some sort of punchline I
can tell I distinctly remember actively
disliking this movie whereas I did not
actively dislike the first of a second
action I actually liked the first when
it came out and I liked the second this
was the first x-men film I'm like ooh I
hate this no but most most people really
hated it and I like I said maybe if I
watch it again I'll see it more cuz I
did just turn off my brain the the first
time as I'm sure here we go it maybe
I'll see the genius of the other two and
the fault of this one though let's see
how it works this is x-men the last damn
that's bullshit we can't do VX we're
gonna do the X of course there you can
say CGI it in it's all CGI oh no no like
look there's like a line around the X
yeah all of these comics and more will
be destroyed before your very
I was gonna say they even had like the
Phoenix in there like yeah that's what
you're about to see oh I forgot about
this I I bet these effects are gonna
look oh the aging of fags remember looks
like completely what's worse he looks a
lot worse oh now he looks bad cetera et
cetera this is a trailer for the new
x-men movie now Rob singer is back he's
gonna do Phoenix right now right I saw a
sneak peek and apocalypse of him doing
Phoenix right finally they're gonna nail
it
I'm glad the music at least gets a
little better with each movie editing
the first one again I'm like oh my god
this music so what happens if they fuck
up and actually get to hit like Hogwarts
have I ever flirt me for showing you
you're a guy Bobby reminds on me on one
point
well that's sexist Wow okay so this was
the one thing where I'm like this is the
only thing in the film I really love
absolutely Patrick Stewart perfectly
cast Ian McKellen pretty good a lot of
the cast is good kelsey Grammer's beast
I'm like I can't humanly possibly think
of a better person to play yeah like I
was like holy crap nav set lost him
crossing the border but we did get a
consolation prize Osama bin Laden's a
mutant tell me where is Magneto and then
while we're at it where's Hannibal
Lecter see this is already more action
than this yeah no this has so many more
memorable scenes you realize the level
of impact this will have on the mutant
community yes I do
to me this is light-years more
interesting cool well I'm sure we'll all
come to a great conclusion it doesn't
work that that's where it sucks I still
don't get how he teaches like all these
different ages at once they're the smart
kids the idiots are hanging out with
Wolverine go punch something professor
Logan I feel like this is a remedial
class shut up and get finger-painting
Pub
I like to imagine that Ellen Page
age is still in Inception and you know
x-men 3 and it's all it's all like yeah
and instead are you watching it you know
is it ain't good I saw the first episode
and it was all right it just looks like
Kitty Pryde when it opened up her own ex
school there call me gonna kill her
first class kind of brought up it's why
I liked first class kind of look and
everything these three did it was just
like okay can we go how do we make this
good yeah you know you're talking to do
you oh oh balloon falls on you it's dead
keep it up I'll spray you in the face
bitch get out of here I'm gonna kill you
myself how would you like to be the kid
that has that line you get to tell a cop
I get I'm gonna kill you if I hurry kid
I'd be like this rolls awesome
you can turn people bold you're like
reverse rogue a you have an amazing gift
Thank You Jimmy that's a great scene
like there's a lot of really good scenes
in this movie it doesn't work but but
have some like a Kelsey Grammer here
he's the only thing that anchors in this
movie oh yeah this place really shows
you how little impact the ending Baxter
yes
Prabhat was Jean Jean I'll say the most
I ever care for these people is probably
in this movie have you ever given the
shit about Cyclops no I don't right now
no but you're close he's great he
possibly still has more lines in this
the next to the mast more straws than
scarecrow powers wrapped her in a cocoon
of telekinetic energy yeah what a cool
little people really bubbly there's no
aliens that's all that matters created a
series of psychic barriers to isolate
her powers from her conscious mind and
as a result gene develops a dual
personality so why did you do that
Xavier is gonna fuck her up you know
it's funny as far as I know that's not
in the comic but he has done things like
that so many times in the cop
it's like what do you think about like
wait that's awful
Logan you have to understand talking
about a person's mind here about Jean
she has to be control control again in
interesting divide between them it's
like yeah he kind of did do something
cool you know what do we telling you
this guy movie is around me it doesn't
resolve anything
I agree by much rather be like oh that's
interesting than just such a messy of
man the whole time because sons growing
up into Owen Wilson Wow wings wings Wow
wings wings Wow
oh syringe Wow yes okay I always said
the action in this room was the best I
see what I wanted she turns back into
the what do they call you
juggen old speech I can't imagine why
you're gonna let me out of here I need a
pee bitch the following show no
seriously what does that thing do fix
your hair sorry I got ahead of myself
and try again in a few minutes hold that
thought you know what don't hold that
thought think of something totally
different
I'll be right back kittens kittens
puppies ha gee maybe add they set this
up more in the other two movies
this would be affecting but Rob she
stared blankly with little fire that's
all you need
what have you done oh not much even
though I wanted to shall give me the
ring and you shall have a queen oh look
down on me in despair
you know I okay like this I scam like oh
well that's that's a cool scene and
maybe that's what and maybe these are
just these are cool scenes but they
don't go together and don't go together
at all the cool ideas but they don't go
the other one has less cool scenes but
it was a more cohesive narrative what do
we do
Professor Xavier start at this school
perhaps it's best that it end with him
again just shows the impracticality of
this school it's like he's got well the
school is gone like I mean were there no
other people oh yeah their fucking work
even when they leave the school is
completely unguarded even when it's
guarded it's unguarded did he not have a
trust fund they're like you know giant
pile of money I'm making money
yeah cannot stop staring at that fly I
noticed that too yeah that's her a for
high def television what it feels
swallow it like pelican Raiders of the
Lost Ark why can't you just let her go
you know when I had these conversations
with Cyclops there were way less
sexually intense
Who am I kidding no they were they
really more sexually intense we have our
mascot guy in a concentration camp once
he's getting very Hitler so I first saw
this movie might be concerned was about
the boy of the little boy that they need
is gonna kill by just realized that
wasn't the
the intent was supposed to be all this
other stuff I said this too much shit
going up yeah now from what I remember
last time I saw this one was in the
theater I this I remember going like
this is awesome but you do it take the
picture that is awesome
and it still holds up man no this was
the one like when it was like what do
you remember from x-men 3 that was good
this is it
oK we've been seeing a lot it seems like
that's a cool scene that's a cool scene
that's good
there's cool seams in this move there's
cool scenes none of which hold a candle
it's the idea of like the cable car and
then you see the bridge like it feels
like you're really there like this is
how about you're looking up at that yeah
they gave it some weights like this is
how to do CGI right God don't you know I
am I'm the germinal bitch so a small
group of teams is very happy
everyone else is unbelievably annoyed
that we did that I didn't even know the
mean by their point so it's just like
well that's weird it's just a weird life
Tranter said there comes a time when all
men yo get the point
it's great that he can be so dignified
but he can go so silly too I mean he's
totally I mean it's great hey buddy
remember rogue and she's a dirt cars
that's my point you're like okay so
there's a whole cartoon and there's yet
that cartoon was dedicated to that ropes
just simply vanished from this fucking
movie okay but this all looks awesome
and I'm having a ball
I like to it wasn't like just one he's
like four he said that more like he was
annoying like no god yeah from here on
out I check out it doesn't look good
there's no interesting character nothing
need happens are you doing anything
tonight
again though the wettest special effects
are great like about the movie I was
just like man that was really cool if
you don't you keep saying that but we've
come across something like ten scenes
where like okay that's cool I like the
action well bad looks nice well that
idea is going there is more than just
well it's this warm thing no there's a
lot of good they Chinese agents that I
guarantee you outside of Beast
I will forgotten about in a day just
like I did last time
I'm air much more in this movie that do
the other to Jesus it's looking like a
military cemetery cosec East's well
that's so stupid I love it and I was in
this to really we can't even get our
goddamn highways fix in this stupid
country Golden Gate Bridge nearly back
up and show tourism
oh yeah there it is um mm-hmm nor like
uh it's I I will give you credit is
definitely worse than I remember it
good that's that's a baby stuff but this
movie went by the fastest out of the
three well I've always said that's Bryan
Singer's Achilles heel if you go by yes
in some ways more entertaining but I
actively hate it more structurally yeah
I definitely see the are two films are
better it's not a good movie I never
says a good movie I think it is I'll
give it to you for entertaining projects
apocalypse drove me even more of a wall
it's the most entertaining because it's
got some decent action scenes in it that
doesn't that and and yes I love Kelsey
Grammer as B's that does not make it
necessarily worthwhile watching like you
can put you can string together any
number of things and you know can be
mildly entertaining to watch that
doesn't mean that it's like oh I'm gonna
watch this again because it just went
nowhere
there you go we'll see you at the best
the x-men movies all that one I'm
driving that what I'm really driving so
here we go we'll see you then bye
you